antonio brown of the pittsburgh steelers
for now he clearly wants out
he wants a new contract he wants to be
called mr big chest things that we
learned in a nine minute video posted by
ab
on instagram last night and that will be
the story of the day he tweeted
yesterday be clear or misunderstood
chris there isn't anything clear
about
antonio brown at this point
we know he wants out that's the one
thing that's clear we know he wants more
money but how this is going to play out
i have no idea and i think as this guy
pokes the steelers at some point he is
going to find himself on the wrong end
of a suspension for conduct detrimental
of the team the team has weapons under
the cba at some point if he keeps this
up they're going to use them well yeah
they're going to use them or they're
just going to sit back and go hey we got
no rush to trade you they're just going
to hold them hostage for for you know a
number of reasons i mean it's a laundry
list of reasons all together and you
know again he's trying to get traded or
moved to another team you know
first impressions matter and i know this
isn't the first impression but here he
is at the first time in his career where
other teams are legitimately
legitimately looking at the prospects of
acquiring this guy and
it's a new news story every other day
right now with antonio brown and yeah i
don't know where it goes from the
steelers but you know like even the
tweet he sent out can we bring that up
kristen in the back there because that's
another one you talk about mixed
messages not for the money is for the
love of the sport the commitment to win
relentlessly consistently passionately
plus i made 70 million it's public
record not to be cocky just the truth
time to play for my own team ab-84 the
family damn that's not going to be good
coaches don't want to read that wait
you're talking about your relentless and
you're passionate and then you're going
to talk about i need more money because
i got people in my family to feed
just the wrong way to approach it that's
the only thing i'm trying to say out
there right now that makes no sense to
me mike
well and that was part of the questions
he was answering over the weekend on
twitter because he was asked are you
doing this because you want a new
contract and his his tweet was
inconsistent he says no but he's playing
for his family right well if you're
playing for your family then you want
every last dollar you can get and he
made it clear in that video while
getting in his late night cardio that he
indeed wants a new contract here's more
from mr big chest
if your team got guaranteed money
tell them call me
a b can't do no more guarantees
so we clear
i want to try to be clear
and understand something
this is not a game people
this is not for show
this is not to be cool
this is strictly to inspire you
that
yo
no one could determine your destination
but
you yeah i'm reminded of remember when
charlie sheen had that weird stretch
like seven or eight years ago and it was
like what the hell is wrong with charlie
she's winning i feel like tiger's blood
i feel like that's where we are with
antonio brown yeah you know look i mean
i i don't want to make light of the
situation if there's something that that
needs to be addressed from a medical
standpoint because those are real issues
and i mean there's a point where this
isn't just stick this isn't just some
sort of a strategy you have to wonder is
this guy okay and should somebody close
to him
be making sure he is okay because
what we've seen manifested since the end
of the 2018 season
no team wants that right did what
assurance do you have if you trade for
antonio brown that he's going to go
back to being the guy who was largely
quiet and anonymous for most of his
career but for the fact that he'd show
up for training camp in a helicopter or
a rolls royce or you know a dump truck
or whatever the case maybe reggie wayne
did that too it was kind of funny but
for the most part you didn't hear from
ab now you hear from maybe all the time
is it going to end once he has a new
team because if i'm a coach if i'm a gm
if i'm an owner if i'm a quarterback if
i'm a teammate i don't want this all the
time and and i think that's going to be
the biggest challenge in getting a team
to trade for him regardless of how it
unwinds in pittsburgh how do you get a
team comfortable with the idea that once
antonio brown is part of your
organization
he's going to go back to being the
normal guy that we thought he was for
most of his career yeah right well i
mean right now the best way for antonio
brown and if i had to do you know hey
here's the chris sims you know advice
for getting a new trade or getting a new
contract the opposite yeah do the
opposite
what would be
be quiet be a professional don't say
anything
act like you almost want to repair your
relationship with the pittsburgh
steelers even if you don't really want
to put the perception out there like you
want to that's going to make other teams
and owners more comfortable with the
aspect of oh we might bring this guy in
but right now he's just adding fuel to
the fire of this guy's a loose cannon uh
antonio brown and we don't know what to
do because we've never seen anything
like this like never i mean with all the
crazy personalities we've had in the
history of the nfl
i mean t.o randy moss whoever it is
whoever you want to go that's
anti-establishment in the nfl odell
beckham jr whoever you want to throw
into this category nobody has done it to
this extent and yet i feel like to a
degree still even though we're talking
about it right now he's a guy that
somewhat gets a free pass in it for some
reason and i don't i don't get that
either at times
is he getting a free pass here
now i know we're not going to do that
and and here's the thing here's the
thing and we made this point yesterday
he's got a weapon available to him that
terrell owens didn't have in 2005 when
he wanted more money from the eagles
because that's how that all started he
had the first season in philly he was a
transcended talent that year he had the
broken ankle late in the season when he
had the horse collar tackle from roy
williams which at the time was a legal
maneuver he got dragged down from behind
broke his ankle right came back and had
a great super bowl would have been the
mvp if the eagles had won the game after
that he was moving into a period in his
contract where he didn't have guarantees
he wanted more guarantees he wanted to
be compensated for what he had done in
2004 and what he was going to do in
2005. that's what set the stage for all
that ugliness but he didn't have social
media available to him to agitate that
way can you imagine the tweets that
would have been posted by terrell owens
in 2005 as stuff was going down in the
locker room as he was getting into
fights with guys and and just you know
disrespecting coaches and doing
everything he could to get traded or
released that's where brown is and your
advice to him is good advice
if it would have been something that he
heeded
at the end of the 2018 season yeah right
but right now what if he would all of a
sudden get quiet we'd be like he's it's
it's more erratic behavior from antonio
brown like we're accepting this as
normal that we're going to see an
outlandish tweet from him every day i
mean we're kind of conditioned to accept
outlandish tweets from certain people in
our society now where we're just used to
it now it's like getting into a hot
bathtub after a while you get used to it
yeah that's how we are with antonio
brown if all of a sudden he shuts up
we'd be like something's wrong now he
now he's quiet and what's he up to and
uh i i look i wouldn't want him
if i'm another team i don't want antonio
brown i don't care how talented he is
there's too many unknowns there's too
many uncertainties there's too many
headaches and there's not the guarantee
necessary that once he comes to your
town you're not going to be next year or
the year after that on the wrong end of
the treatment that he's directing at the
steelers now yeah exactly right i mean
you'll you trade for him right now i'm i
feel the same way with you if i was
running a football team a head coach of
the football team whatever it may be i
wouldn't feel comfortable about it i
mean you you you could very quickly find
yourself in mike tomlinville where
everyone goes huh you don't have control
of your football team
why i mean that's why we talk about mike
tomlin the way we do at times because of
one guy it's really been antonio brown
for the most part of all the issues of
the steelers and even to the to randy
moss uh you know ocho cinco all those
guys that we think we put in the class
with antonio brown i don't want to
disrespect them and say that they're not
they are not they never did some of the
things that antonio brown has done
they've never disrespected their team or
coaches the way antonio brown has at any
point they might have been annoying
because they you know t.o did
celebrations and yeah he wasn't loved by
everybody in the locker room but he they
didn't go like awol and miss practice or
you know do instagram live from the
locker room or throw gatorade uh jugs on
the sidelines or you know reading their
lips cussing out coaches on the
sidelines and everything else they you
know that that's where i will
you know
respect them and say
they don't deserve to be thrown into the
class of what antonio brown is right now
uh flying off the handle
the real question is how is this going
to play out is this going to be
something where the steelers find a
trade partner or just get exasperated
and cut antonio brown last week ed
boucher the post because that was on the
program and he said the steelers should
take a conditional seventh rounder in
2020 if that's what it takes to get rid
of him
if at some point they stand up and fight
back the way the eagles fought back
against terrell owens is going to hover
over the team all season long and you
will see suspensions the one device that
teams don't have now and the reason they
don't have it now is because of what the
eagles did to terrell owens sending the
guy home with pay remember the
buccaneers did that with keyshawn
johnson were you on the bus
you can't send a guy home with pay
anymore but you can suspend him for up
to four weeks at a time for conduct
detrimental to the team
and i look i i can't recall a team ever
suspending a guy for off-season conduct
detrimental to the team but is this not
the definition of it if you are out
there making it clear that you intend to
violate your contract that you want
someone to come sign you when you're not
a free agent you've got three years left
under contract and you're you're
agitating you're you're calling out your
quarterback you're calling out your
coach you're disrespecting your owner at
some point i think the steelers are
going to stand up and take action
against him and it's going to set the
stage see he's banking on the steelers
not wanting another year of drama and
dysfunction right and that he's going to
be so disruptive that they just don't
want it that's what he's hoping for yeah
but you know one thing is going to say
screw it well you're right well then
first of all they can't just cut them no
you you can't just let a guy act a fool
and then say okay we're going to give
you your way now and let you go to
whatever team you want there's no way
you want to talk about losing
institutional control on your football
team in a hurry that'll be a quick way
to do it you can't do that you can't
release him at this point he's called
your bluff you got to play hardball with
them right now that's what they're going
to have to do and to the fact of
dysfunction into the season and all that
things i think most of the team in
pittsburgh has already wrapped their
head around that antonio brown won't be
there so whether he's being suspended or
not or not just sitting on the sidelines
doing whatever it is i think the players
have already conditioning their brains
to go he's not going to be helping us
out so it wouldn't be you know i don't
think it would be as shocking maybe as
we would think
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports